and now ladies and gentlemen you come to
the next award which is considered by
the stars as the one most cherished as
you know they've been rehearsing
together down here the past two days and
they work closely together and made some
lasting friendships and the Congeniality
award is voted by them this year there
is no winner it's been some time since
our next two presenters have graced the
Oscar festivities we're pleased to have
welcomed them back again would you
welcome please James Coburn and Kim
Novak
people were surprised at him down all
the way from Carmel to be here with us
tonight well I do have a very very fine
like there what I think everyone would
like living there yeah beautiful why
don't we find out but we could all go up
there
I don't show today let's talk about that
one later but in the meantime I just
want to say I'm really honored and very
proud to be here with the industry
ignite now the artists that are
nominated for the outstanding
achievement in cinematography are Nestor
Alvin Brooks for Donal Sigmund but the
deer hunter William a Fraker for heaven
can wait another two T's was same time
next year
Oswald Morris for the width and the
winner is Ness tremendous
I would like to first say something in
Spanish un saludo ato de las personas de
habla espanol ax en estados unidos en
America I would like to thank all the
people that helped to get these images
all the camera operators and very
specially has the Wexler who came at the
end of the movie when I had to leave on
a previous commitment I want to thank
the producers house and Virgin Ida and
very of course director Terrence Malick
these images belong entirely to him this
Oscar it should be for him thank you